[Music]
and here we go the moment you've all
been waiting for time for our jeopardy
warm-up we get to see which of our
contestants
knows the most about las vegas so our
contestants tonight
we are excited to to welcome kevin
martin to the mix
she's going to do great ted florindo is
an old hat at this and brian has been
busy riding it's raining it's pouring
the old man
we're not going to ask about the rain
this is a completely different kind of
question kevin
we've got 15 seconds to answer our clue
we're going to start the clock as soon
as we read
the clue so whoever wins gets their
bragging rights and a milkshake tonight
really hard i got to win
okay so here is our clue tonight this
iconic figure has been watching over
fremont street for
over 70 years i'm gonna get that
milkshake
of time you yep have a pretty good track
on who this might be
yeah i know he's that too please okay
we're taking oh we're taking milkshake
orders everyone's feeling so cold
cherry no cherry 15 seconds we need a
little cocky ted
we're wrong all right um kevin pen's
down
time's up would you like i was a teacher
in another life would you like to share
your answer what did you think it is
i'm first she's got this she's got this
here's your answer of course vegas vic
here for a long time over
fremont street experience fellas how did
you do ted
vegas vic now at circa right
um no that's vegas vicky right yeah his
girlfriend his girlfriend
vegas vicky yeah i don't know okay
yeah i believe i yeah
i'm just kidding oh there you go
chocolate
this is what it looks like now vegas
vicki as you know is now inside the
circa hotel